[Music]
okay so um you saw two of them tonight
and we saw one of them yesterday when we
saw yesterday we re watched dead don't
die
yeah and that movie under repeat
viewings does hold up in fact I think
it's better yeah it's a very
well-constructed movie the taller that
movies really good is really comforting
to watch that movie in a weird way yeah
you know what's really weird and I told
him me at this yesterday I was like we
work out home from watching it I was
like this really makes me want to watch
a Coen Brothers movie specifically
Raising Arizona it just it reminds me of
that kind of tone yeah it's not a fast
paced movie no it's just just but it
goes along at the right pace and you're
enjoy and it has it's going and you're
laughing at you're laughing at people
there's a lot of clever [ __ ] happening
in the movie like this is what would
actually happen like if the zombie
apocalypse ever did happen in this
particular way this is how it would go
down like in this vault that's like
everybody would be kind of like yeah
yeah I told you so it wouldn't be yeah
wouldn't they like this big like
everyone's screaming and wailing and
looting and everything like that it
would just be like this really low-key
so I think that's like yeah the best
aspect of the movie for me like that is
it goes and gets self-aware they're like
well you know I read the script you know
and then they start talking about the
director in the middle of the [ __ ]
movie and Bill Murray just knocks it out
of the park so does Adam driver I mean
the whole cast is awesome yeah I mean
the interaction between the two of them
is like easily the best part of the
movie they're just like so dry and so
funny and they like play very well off
each other and they don't even really
have to say anything
now you just know it's like their facial
expressions and stuff and that the one
part like after the the zombies first
strike and they like these two women and
then just that whole sequence where like
the cops come and like they go one at a
time they all go in a look at the
they held like that the [ __ ] of
reactions that are just priceless and I
don't know if like anybody else could
pull that off and on second viewing Tom
Waits was really an important part of
that movie yeah more important that I
remembered him on the first he did a
really good job there was a cool
character Herman Herman Bob is totally
unaffected by the zombie apocalypse
he's like a narrator yeah but yeah we've
you know like I said since we have the
a-list things sometimes were like well
there wasn't a lot watching
we just wanted to see I mean we were
actually gonna see Toy Story 4 this week
but then with the times don't work out
yeah so we just went ahead and watched
it don't die again because we liked it
so much the first I want to buy this on
blu-ray
flow-rate it's like a blu-ray is that is
the triple out on blu-ray yeah it's
definitely definitely worth getting I
think like I said if you like that kind
of like you know very dry kind of humor
then yeah yeah
you
okay we saw Ana - Ana was story about a
KGB assassin she's also like a fashion
model that's our cover it's basically a
lot like La Femme Nikita well same
direct it's the same director elements
and the occasional yeah this is so you
know yeah that's why it's like look I'm
Nikita because it's yeah although I must
say this was not a bad movie I like to
defend Nikita better well I did yeah
classic right but I actually didn't mind
this one my favorite part of this one I
think I liked Killian Murphy's character
he was like the csca a guy and I also
really liked Helen Mirren's character
she's like a higher up in the KGB and
she was yeah there's only one thing that
I didn't like about the movie I thought
totally it had it had a one problem
where normally the movies kind of
serious yeah and I liked that but then
sometimes when she would go on these
missions it would go straight John wick
and she would start doing things that
were just not possible for a hundred and
ten pound woman to do you know what I
mean she'd have five guys on her that
you know each one of them weighed 20
pounds
when to 40 pounds more than her and she
still beat their asses I just it just
kind of took me out of it it was just
not just the combat scenes just they
weren't they were stylistic yeah they
weren't realistic and to me it was like
a tonal clash between a kind of
realistic movie and then all of a sudden
those stylistic fights yeah it didn't
see if it seemed like that that the
fight scenes came from another movie
like if the rest of the movie was
over-the-top John wick style it would
have worked yeah but it was just too
damn realistic a lot of the times and
then it goes into that and I was just
like I just didn't I didn't like the
fight scenes but overall it was a decent
movie I liked it like it kept me
involved
I kind of liked the way you know since a
European director it wasn't structured
like a you know what what it would do
generally is like they would have like a
situation unfold you know and you were
like surprised by the outcome of the
situation and then they would go oh
three months ago yeah flashback set it
all up so you'd be like oh that's how
that goes so they did that several times
so that's how the movie was structured
so you really kind of had to pay
attention to follow it because yeah it
wasn't it straight and they're doing
that because of spycraft they want you
to see what it would look like if you
were just saw it yourself
yeah you'd you'd have bought the
deception but then it go wave and hold
on and they back let me show you this
what yeah this is where everything that
they which I really did I liked that I
usually like I usually like very linear
movies but I understand why they did it
that way yeah he did it that my only
complaint was the difference in the tone
of the damn fight scenes I can see what
you're saying the read the rest of the
movie didn't match that John get [ __ ]
you know I mean now I think they're
gonna they're we ever choreographed that
fight and [ __ ] the same stuff that
scoria grabbed the stuff off option I
was thinking it was I can't see now
they're gonna do like they do with the
matrix we're all [ __ ] fighting we'll
look like something out of the matrix
remember they did that for a while I
hope they don't do that because that
[ __ ] that fighting style looks good
in a John Witt movie you know it's a
comic book movie yeah you know and and
this the rest of the movie didn't seem
like a comic book movie yeah and then if
you go back to the Femme Nikita there
was a lot of combat now but it was just
vicious yeah you know I mean it wasn't
real flamboyant it was just vicious yeah
yeah and that's another thing about it
they showed some of her of the all the
missions or little excerpts from the
missions that she did before and they
made it look like the missions were a
little too easy I thought yeah actually
just walk them through and she was just
murdering guys yeah but that's not
that's not easy to do either and at
least there's risk cops and all kinds of
stuff you know it made it look a little
too easy I think but it was a good movie
yeah
I kept interested yeah what I want to
see it again
try not though on the Femme Nikita I
could watch that three or four times a
half yeah but I just didn't feel like
I'd want to see this one again yeah I
mean I feel like if you liked La Femme
Nikita you should probably check it out
yeah I don't think it's as good as that
I don't think it is either
but but I thought it was pretty good you
know yeah
okay we saw child's play this is a hard
reboot of the original child's play with
Chucky and I gotta say it's a perfect
summer perfect summer horror movie they
get all the old school notes this is
like like a really good movie from the
late 80s Early 90s yeah
it's a different Chucky originally you
know Chuck he's a doll that was
possessed by dude coming off a death row
that's not the situation you're dealing
with a basically an animatronic toy it's
like a little robot and it can you know
it can it can like a I think yeah and it
can it can access the the cloud and it
can hijack you know electronics and and
there's something wrong with this and I
don't want to really spoil everything
you know I'm gonna explain what it is
it's not know what there there is some
there is a possibility that there might
be something paranormal going on they
leave that open yeah remember how this
thing happened there might be something
paranormal mixed with something
technological going on yeah but it's not
really answered but there's a lot of kid
that the hero is like a 13 year old boy
and this thing's trying to kill his
friends it does kill some of his friends
and something and I just got it tries to
kill his mom and there's a lot of kids
in this in this movie and thankfully not
a single Kenny none of the none of the
kids are annoying or obnoxious they all
knock it out of the park all real good
performances and you know you're rooting
for the kids and the kids say some funny
[ __ ] yeah kids say some funny [ __ ] like
the mom is likable the neighbors and
it's a you know it's got a lot of
graphic violence and then there's a lot
of really good scenes where they're
[ __ ] with your mind and [ __ ] it was
just a perfect summer I would call this
like a thriller action horror adventure
with comedy also comment I mean I'm
gonna say I mean the original was kind
of a comedy - yeah it had funny parts oh
this one I think they leaned into the
comedy
but more its I don't know if I'd call it
a straight comedy but it definitely had
a lot of comedic elements in it yeah
and I actually think it was much funnier
than the original it is the interactions
where the characters are funny just like
the whole the way they react to the
situation's is funny you know and I like
what they did with the doll it's like
it's creepy they made him look different
yeah I mean if you seen the trailers
yeah he's more powerful than the
original Chucky yeah and because
technology's involved and things like
wireless and Bluetooth he's at actually
it opens up more doors for things to
happen
and just because you destroy this
thing's body is it in the internet now
will it can it get into another one
later you know you don't you know we
guess it's not a soul because they go
this they show a scene of how what made
this thing different and a death did
occur yeah so you don't know maybe if it
was you know I'm talking about that so
it is open to that yeah so there might
be slightly possessed you don't know and
I like the fact that they didn't really
come out and tell you what the problem
what the problem was so and I thought it
was a masterpiece in its genre for it's
funny because I'm not a huge I mean I'm
not like oh you remakes or anything like
that like I wish they would do more
original ones but I was like oh I liked
the original child's play but I'm not
one of those people that's like oh they
don't we make up it wasn't a great movie
yeah it's a good movie was not one of my
favorite this one they not a teleport
man this one was a lot of fun and we do
it with you know kind of a late yeah the
crowd was loving it yeah it's like it
was so much better it was like laughing
and screaming it covering their eyes up
and [ __ ] like that it was a blast it's
really it's a throwback movie they use
Diggs exactly the same techniques and
the same thing that they always did for
the 80s and the 90s to make a great
movie like this they they did exactly
what they had to do yeah I really like
and they even had some callbacks to like
row
they know they knew exactly what kind of
movie this was and that's that was that
it's just like a fun game read just like
you know one you'd brent with your
friends back in the 80s that yeah
exactly and they even have like a no
basho Texas Chainsaw man yeah there was
some stuff that kind of felt like coke
like poltergeist her poultrygeist wand
or some callbacks to [ __ ] Robocop it
knew what kind of movie it was yeah and
and at all and it was a masterpiece of
that genre I think it will go down
pretty well I think I think it will be I
think probably it's like yeah you can
okay let me ask you this let me ask you
this what would you rather see again
that again or men in black international
yeah rather see this one muscle yeah
much rather super funny yeah I buy this
on blu-ray yeah it had that kind of
comforting feeling of an 80's 90's and
then they do it and they go yeah that's
it and then the music was right the
modern David they did it the right way
it almost felt like a dad Spielberg
movie in a weird way sometimes like an
old Spielberg movie yeah
[Music]